it's a bold call a lot of times
investors or analysts will make these
calls for publicity but I'm guessing you
think this is a legit target well yeah
we definitely think it's a legit target
or we wouldn't be doing it
discredit ourselves you know we were
actually one of the first in them in the
market to call the original Tesla you
know short squeeze and April a few years
ago and and we were right there we
stayed away from the stock for a while
because it's really needed to digest
this momentum it's had as we move into
the next phase in the next product cycle
that they've got which is where we're at
point in time right now and as we sort
of size up where things are going in the
future we see that you know it's it's it
rather be a bull and a bear on the stock
going into the products like what they
have right now I think it's important to
point out your history with this stock
because I recall at the time pretty much
everybody was a sell on Tesla and you
are one of the very few investors that
kind of swam against the stream and I'm
guessing he made a lot of money on that
trade we did we did very well and our
funds did very well that you know there
during that period of time and and you
have a it's like we've stayed away from
it for a while I haven't owned it but
we're back in it going forward because I
just look at the Model X is the big
make-or-break moment for you know this
company Elon Musk is I shoot the moon
strategist type person it's an
all-or-nothing kind of thing and the
Model X is the the next product cycle
that's going to turn them into sort of
the next Apple as a business so a
success with this product release is
something that puts them well on the
pathway to to what they're trying to do
with their longer-term vision yeah I
took a look at your at your presentation
five reasons Tesla's going to hit $500
by year and I have to say that the model
act strikes me as the most important
reason because if they do well with this
V if with this vehicle the sky's the
limit really until the until the third
vehicle has to come out but it's a big
if right because Elon Musk is great at
at putting up as you say moon targets
but he's often very very late I mean the
Model X already should be here it's been
late you know so far but I think that
just goes to the the focus that they
have on product quality and also knowing
that this is a make-or-break kind of
thing for them so they're not going to
a product that isn't perfect and isn't
gonna delight you know sort of consumers
and isn't going to be something that was
better than the Model S was when it came
out which as we remember sort of one car
of the year and all the accolades and
the success they've had coming forward
since then so I'm expecting them to
deliver something that's really going to
you know amaze the market and there's
plenty of you know PR news announcements
other kinds of things that you know
they've kept up their sleeve that I'm
sure is gonna you're gonna see going
forward in the next six months as they
roll things out what about the battery
business I mean that seems like a big
question mark as well it's very
interesting obviously to talk about and
think about but there doesn't seem to be
any real use case for these sort of
homes energy storage batteries well not
yet but if you look just where the world
is going you know it's it's a well-known
you know kind of understanding it with
the shifting of you know reusable power
in order to get solar powers to store
the stuff off peak and the generated
back on peak is a massive you know sort
of the next big thing and you know in
the world like something that will be
akin to the internet was with energy
storage and they're really well
positioned as a business because there's
so many ways in terms of driving the
cost of batteries down that they can
turn those things into massive things
and be a huge winner with inside of that
you know side that segment that's
definitely part of their core strategy
and long-term vision where they're going
today its cars but going forward it's
about energy density and energy storage
go only a few minutes really here left
but I got to ask you what you think Elon
Musk is worth because you've got to be a
big value of this company well you know
that to me that's the biggest tail risk
of the business I maybe if this plane
gets hit tomorrow I mean that's it
that's gonna be the biggest tail risk
that exists inside of inside of Tesla so
a huge huge component to the brand the
person